Das ist gut.
Bitte schön.
Ja, okay.
Hallo Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Abidhan.
Ich bin hier zuständiger Assenaristin.
Mit Ihnen werde ich das Anamnese gesprechen.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Eva Schmidt.
Eva Schmidt.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
STH MIDT.
DT.
Okay.
Verstanden.
Wie alt sind Sie Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
73 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Eine Ahnung.
Okay.
Vielleicht können wir später noch mal sagen.
Ausweis kontrollieren.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 177 groß und fiege 70.
70.
Okay.
Ich bin 177 groß und fiege 70.
Ich bin 197 groß und fiege 70.
Frau Schmidt.
Was ist das mit uns?
Ich habe Luftnot.
Luftnot?
Ja.
Ich habe Luftnot.
Vor allen Dingen.
Wenn ich schlafe, muss ich viel husten.
Wenn ich nachts schlase,
dann muss ich viel husten.
Aber am schlimmsten wird das mit dem Acid.
Luftnot zusammenarbeiten.
Luftnot zusammen, aber ich habe beide dann immer Luftnot und Husten. Am schlimmsten wird es morgens um 5, 6 Uhr.
Besonders morgens um 5, 6 Uhr.
Schimpfde geworden. Okay.
Leiden Sie an momentan Atemnot?
Ein bisschen, ja, auch in Ruhe.
Okay. Franci mit, muss ich momentan unser Gespräch unterbrechen.
werde ich Ihre Sauerstoffsetigung messen und ein EKG wird geschrieben.
Verstanden?
Wir haben alles gemacht, alles in Ordnung.
EKG ist ein komplett restgenkelblock Herzrequenz 80 pro Minute.
80 pro Minute? Okay. Franci mit, in ihrer EKG gibt es nicht notwendige Situation.
Deswegen können wir weitergehen.
Notwendige Situation?
Gibt es nichts Sonderes oder nichts Schlimmes oder nichts Akutes?
Nicht Akutes, akute Befunde.
Genau.
Deswegen können wir weitergehen.
Weiter machen.
Weiter machen? Ja.
Okay. Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Atemnot und Husten?
Ich habe das schon länger, ich habe das schon seit Jahren, aber das ist jetzt seit ein paar Tagen sehr schlimm geworden.
Okay.
Konz, Konz, Ihr Auswurf beim Husten?
Husten, nicht Husten.
Ja, ja, Schleim kommt.
Ist das geldlich?
Geldlich, ja, das ist geldlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Auswurf Bluts gesehen?
Also gestern Morgen habe ich sehr viel gehusstet, da war dann am Ende auch ein bisschen Blut mit dabei.
Ja, Kircheblutung, vermutlich.
Was meinen Sie mit Kircheblutung? Ich habe Blut gesehen.
Okay.
Für euch geht es bis zum 5. Auslöse, für ihre Bechverden?
Vor allen Dingen nachts, wenn ich mich und morgens ist, ist es am schlimmsten.
Ja, morgens.
Leiden Sie unter Brust, Schmerzen?
Nein.
Okay. Hatten Sie früher auch die Endnische, Bechverden?
Ja, das auch schon mal.
Waren Sie beim anderen Arzt?
Ja, ich bin beim Lumenfacharzt in Therapie.
Lungen Therapie?
Lumenfacharzt, wenn ich in Therapie, ja.
Lumentherapie kann man nicht sagen, das gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Herzen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich spiele, leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nein.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden lindert oder verstärkt?
Nicht, dass ich möchte.
Ich möchte. Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Fibar, fühlen Sie sich piblig?
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht warm.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit gribale Infektion gehabt?
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit griffal infektion gehabt?
Ganz schlecht.
Hatten Sie, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit bestimmte Infektionen gehabt?
Ja, ich habe immer wieder Atemweginfektionen.
Wann war letzte Infektion?
Sie meinen, ich habe das letzte Mal nicht an Antibiotikum eingenommen?
Ja, genau.
Vor zwei Monaten.
Bekommen Sie Atemweginfektionen sehr häufig?
Ja.
Atemwegeinfektionen ist falsch. Atemwegsinfektionen.
Atemwegsinfektionen.
Sehr gut.
Atemweginfektionen.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Das klappt ganz gut bei mir.
Wie apathetisch?
Mein Apetit ist nicht so gut in letzter Zeit.
Ich schlafe auch nicht so gut.
Mein Mann ist vor drei Monaten gestorben oder bläger sogar.
Ich glaube, hier sind schon fünf Monate.
Aber seitdem kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Ich habe auch keinen Apetit, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin auch sehr traurig.
Vor fünf Monaten, ja.
Ist mir leid.
Danke.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt, apotheos zu genommen?
Ich esse halt weniger, ne?
Ich habe schon abgenommen.
Ich habe so in den letzten zwei Monaten, habe ich so zehn Kilo abgenommen.
Zehn Kilometer.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt.
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Können Sie, äh,
wenn ich genüge Wasser trinken,
genüge Wasser trinken?
Ich esse nicht so viel, dann trink ich auch nicht so viel.
Nicht so viel.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen von denen ich wissen soll,
zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Blutzückigkeit?
Ja, ja.
Ich habe einen Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Ich habe Östöporose.
Ich habe, ähm,
Seopedi.
Zeitwann, äh,
Leidenseopedi,
Anseopedi.
Leidenseopedi, ich habe schon seit,
seit Sicharen.
Seit Sicharen.
Okay.
Zeitwann, haben Sie Artillerien, Quartoni?
Nein,
Bluthochdruck.
Leidenseopedi.
Nein,
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Und wenn Sie Medikamente,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein.
Ich nehme das ASS 100 ein.
ASS 100.
Weil der Arzt gesagt hat,
dass ich eine Durchblutungstörung an den Beinen habe.
Ja.
Ich nehme die Ostoporose ein.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
wie das heißt.
Mit S klingt das an.
Vossamax.
Mit S Schumminkönn.
Vossamax heißt das, glaube ich.
Ich bin ja mal gegen die Ostoporose ein,
einmal die Woche.
Einmal den Urkorn.
Genau.
Dann nehme ich etwas gegen meinen Blutdruck ein.
Die heißen die Tabletten.
Amlo.
Ja.
Zweimal am Tag.
Und dann nehme ich noch ein Medikament ein.
Gegen den Blutdruck, aber ich weiß den Namen nicht mehr.
Okay.
Dann können wir vielleicht,
ihr ihr Plan,
nachgucken, nachschauen.
Ich sage, meine Tochter muss das mitbringen.
Ich habe den nicht dabei.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie oder wenden Sie
bestimmte
Spray
und COPD
an?
Da fällt mir ein.
Ich nehme auch eine Cortison Tablette ein.
Cortison Tablette.
Ja.
Wie viel Milligramm sind das,
die ich jetzt einnehme?
Das hat der Arzt mir jetzt verschwunden.
Ich glaube 20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt seit ein paar Tagen.
Ein paar Tage.
Was soll dann reduziert werden?
Mhm.
Ansonsten haben Sie keine Medikamente.
Einnehmen.
Ich nehme was gegen
meinen Magen ein.
Gegen den Cortison.
Ja.
Antiprosol oder?
Ja, genau.
Das nehme ich ein.
20 Milligramm, 20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm, 2 Mal täglich.
Und es fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Ich habe bestimmt noch etwas.
Es fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Wie bitte?
Alle Tabletten fallen mir jetzt nicht ein.
Okay.
Dann kontrollieren wir alles.
Reagieren Sie auf
Medikamente oder
Stoffe allergisch?
Ja,
penicillin vertrag ich nicht.
Penicillin.
Wie äußert sich Ihre Allergie?
Ich kriege keine Luft
und werde rot am ganzen Körper.
Haben Sie
alle Corona-Impfungen
auch erhalten?
Ich habe 3 Impfungen erhalten.
3 Impfungen.
Haben Sie impf was dabei?
Alles zu Hause.
Okay.
Schaut euch mal an.
Ich bin gestürzt
vor 5 Jahren
und habe eine künstliche Hüfte.
Künstliche Hüfte.
Wurdun Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, künstliche Hüfte.
Ansonsten keine Operation.
Nein.
Okay.
Frech mit Rauchen Sie
oder haben Sie
für die Corona-Impfungen
keine Operation?
Ich kann nicht aufhören.
Ich rauche 2 Packungen am Tag.
2 Packungen?
Ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit meinem 18.
Ja.
18 Jahre.
Über 50 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur bei Gelegenheit.
Am Wochenende
habe ich eine kleine Hüfte.
Ich habe eine kleine Hüfte.
An Wochenende?
Nein. Nur bei Feierlichkeiten.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht.
Jetzt ist mir etwas eingefallen.
Ich nehme noch Sprays ein.
Ich nehme noch 2 Sprays ein.
Spray.
Ja.
Ich nehme noch 2 Sprays ein.
Spray.
Ja.
Ich nehme noch 2 Sprays ein.
Aber ich kenne die Namen nicht.
Namen nicht.
Nehmen Sie nicht per Söhne, sondern medizinische Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Drogen.
Ja.
Wir haben gesagt, dass
ihr Mann
vor 5 Monaten
gestorben ist.
Wir leiden.
Leben
Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein.
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
Meine Eltern sind schon längst tot.
Ja.
In Deutschland ist das eigentlich möglich?
Nein.
Wir sind schon gestorben.
Woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Sie sind alt geworden.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie
chronische Erkrankungen oder erbliche
Krankheiten?
Nicht das ich willste.
Okay.
Sind Sie ein Kind?
Nein.
Ich habe noch 2 Geschwester.
Sind Ihre Schwester gesund?
Ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Leben Sie allein?
Ja.
Ich lebe allein.
Meine Kinder sind schon groß und sind schon aufgezogen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
2 erwachsene Kinder habe ich.
Sind Ihre Kinder auch gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Sind Sie im Rentner?
Ja, ich bin Rentnerin.
Rentnerin.
Welche Beruf hatten Sie?
Ich hatte, ich war Lehrerin.
Lehrerin.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt auch ein
Ausdruckerin.
Ich möchte für Sie kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben ja seit einem Jahr, seit einige Jahren,
haben Sie Atemnot, Luftnot und
Atembeschwerden?
Ich würde nicht sagen,
wenn ich den Patienten kurschelle,
dass die Patienten seit einigen Jahren Luftnot
sondern Atembeschwerden haben.
Atembeschwerden ist besser.
Ich kann ja nicht durchgehen mit Luftnot leben.
Das geht ja nichts.
Dann würde ich immer sagen Atembeschwerden.
Ja, Sie haben seit einigen Jahren Atembeschwerden.
Sie haben ja seit einem Jahr, seit einem Jahr, seit einem Jahr
vor dem Atembeschwerden,
seit einem Morgen, seit einigen Jahren
Sie haben keine Brust zu schmutzten.
Nein.
Sie haben zwei Monate,
um die Brust zu schmutzten.
Ich habe keine Brust zu schmutzten.
Nein.
für zwei Monate haben Sie eine Atemwechsinfektion gelitten und Sie haben eine Antibiotikbehandlung bekommen.
Sie haben eine Antibiotiktherapie bekommen.
Sie haben eine Antibiotiktherapie behandelt.
Sie haben eine Antibiotiktherapie erhalten.
Sie haben eine Antibiotiktherapie bekommen.
Genau.
Oder die Infektion ist mit einem Antibiotikbehandlung behandelt.
Das geht auch.
Sie haben schon lange gesagt, dass es Bluthochdruck gibt.
Sie nehmen die Amlodipin zweimal täglich.
Sie leiden Ostöporoase.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme ein Ostöporoasemittel ein.
Was amax.
Sie haben zwei unbekannte Sprays.
Sie haben zwei Sprays, die Sie nicht kennen oder sich erinnern können.
Sie nehmen einen Tag 20 Milligramm ein.
Sie nehmen ein Tag 20 Milligramm ein.
Seit wann nehmen Sie das?
Seit einigen Tagen.
Ich habe meine Medikamente vergessen.
Ich verstehe Sie, Sie brauchen keine Angst zu haben.
Ich habe Angst, Sie brauchen keine Angst zu haben.
Ich verstehe Sie, wenn Sie stark kusten, bekommt es Blut.
Sie werden etwas blutig.
Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Sie nehmen ein Röntgenbild von der Lunge.
Was waren Sie noch?
Ich werde mit meinem Chef sprechen.
Ich werde mit meinen Chef sprechen.
Sie brauchen eine Minute.
Ja, und danke.
Ja.
Okay, hallo, guten Tag Frau Obererstin.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, also genau.
Man sagt nicht Frau Oberärztin, sondern den Namen, aber ich habe es verstanden.
Okay, alles klar. Ja, ich habe Zeit.
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Frau Eva Schmid ist...
Eva.
Frau Eva Schmid ist 73-jährige Patientin,
ein Meter 76 und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns wegen, seit ein paar Tagen,
5.000 Dispner vor.
Laut der Patientin, 5.000 Dispner seit ein paar Jahren
und beim Schlafen verstarke sich ihr Husten.
Ich habe schon einen EKG geschrieben
und bei der EKG gibt es Reschenkelblock
und Herzprokens 80 Prominut.
Und diese Atemnot sei Hustenabhängig.
Besonders morgens verstarke sich ihre Schputung.
Wenn sie stark Husten bekommen,
sei ihr Schputz blötig.
Und die Frage nach einer Torachschmerz,
einer Torachschmerz, wurde verneint.
Für zwei Monate leidete sie an einer Pynomonie,
die mit Antibiotiktherapie behandelt worden sei.
Die Begratitiver Anamnese sei bis auf Inapotent in Sonia
und in zwei Monaten 10 kg gewischt abnahmend unauffällig.
Die Vorerkrankungen gaben eine Arteriehypertonie,
eine Osteoporose, eine COPD.
Was glauben Sie, warum die Patientin eine Osteoporose hat?
Sie ist im Wechseljahr hochweichlich.
Sie rauche viel Zigaretzen.
Was meinen Sie, was ist das Auschlaggebende für die Patientin,
dass sie eine Osteoporose leidet?
Ich frage Sie, ich will wissen von Ihnen.
Warum Sie glauben, dass sie eine Osteoporose hat?
Sie ist ein predisponierter Faktor, das stimmt.
Warum hat sie eine Osteoporose?
Was meinen Sie?
Sie ist eine Osteoporose.
Was ist eine Osteoporose?
Was ist eine Geschwurz?
Ein Tumor.
Was ist eine Osteoporose?
Es ist eine Schwurz.
Sie hat einen Knochen.
Was macht das unüblich, dass Sie eine Osteoporose haben?
Denken Sie, was macht eine Osteoporose?
Alte Frau.
Ich bin nicht geblieben.
Entschuldigung, wir hören nicht.
Sie sollen nicht Ihre Notizen angucken, sondern überlegen.
Sie haben Knochen, Osteoporose.
Sind Sie verwundert?
Nein, ich bin nicht verwundert.
Warum nicht?
Weil die Patientin eine COPD hat.
Sie haben eine Osteoporose.
Sie haben eine Arteriellehypertone.
Sie nehmen sie am Lübchen 2-mal täglich ein.
Und eine Phosphomax.
Eine Phosphomax.
Nehmen Sie eine Phosphomax.
Und wegen COPD.
Nehmen Sie 2 Spray.
Sie nehmen sie am Lübchen 2-mal täglich ein.
Und wegen COPD.
Nehmen Sie 2 Spray.
Sie nehmen sie am Lübchen 2-mal täglich ein.
Und wegen COPD.
Nehmen Sie 2 Spray.
Sie nehmen sie am Lübchen 2-mal täglich ein.
Und wegen COPD.
Sie haben das bisher sehr gut gemacht.
Ganz langsam.
Langsam konzentriert weitermachen.
Genau.
Außerdem nehmen Sie regelmäßig kurz 20 mg täglich einmal und pantoprosol 20 mg täglich
zweimal ein und wegen PAKO, nein, wegen tiefen Trombol, ja.
Und hat die Patientin, hat sie eine, ihrer Meinung nach, eine Tiefe
wehntrombose oder hat sie eine PAVK?
Nimmt man bei einer tiefen wehntrombose ASS ein?
Nein.
Wann nimmt man ASS ein?
PAVK.
Ja.
Vermutlich hat sie anonymistisch auf eine PAVK und nimmt ASS ein.
Ja, wegen anonymistisch PAVK.
Ja, genau.
Nehmen Sie ASS 100 mg täglich einmal ein?
Sehr gut.
Und ja, die Patientin reagiert auf Penicillin allergisch, ja, okay.
Ihre allergie erscheinende, erscheinende oder reagiert, ihre, okay, ich schuldige
Ihre allergie äußere sich mit Dispnell und Exantem und sie sei allergisch.
Aber das müssen Sie in der Prüfung nicht erklären, wie die Allergie sich auswirkt.
Das müssen Sie wirklich nicht.
Nein, es reicht, wenn die Patientin hat eine Penicillin allergetfertigt und wenn
der Prüfer sie dann fragt, ist das denn auch eine Allergie, woher wissen Sie das
dann sagen Sie ja, die Patientin gibt typische Symptome an, Halsschwellung und
Exantem, aber sonst nicht erzählen.
Reicht wenn Sie sagen, die Patientin hat eine Penicillin allergie wirklich.
Okay.
Sie haben alle Grundinfektionen erhalten, sie sei gegen Corona vorgeimpft und laut der
Patientin, ja, wurde sie wegen Hüfte, Tab, Tab, Zustand nach einem Unfall operiert.
Sie sei Raucherin, seit, ja, okay, seit 55 Jahren Rauch ist die täglich
zwei Packungen und sie trinken gelegenlich im Gesellschaft Alkohol und sein
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Ja, in der Familienanamnese, in der Familienanamnese, oder okay, ihre Eltern
sind gestorben und sie kennen nicht die Ursache und sie haben zwei gesunde Geschwister
und sie leben in Elan, sie haben zwei gesunde Geschwister, vor fünf Monaten
oder eine Pynomonie zustande nach COPD.
Nein, nicht COPD-Attacke, sondern welches Wort benutzen wir, wenn die COPD
Exarbation, COPD-Exarbation hin.
Sehr gut.
Alternativ kommen eine Pynomonie, sehr gut,
und das wichtigste.
Langsam, ist alles gut.
Ja, okay.
Also, hier hat eine, ich sage, also, die Pynomonie, die Pynomonie, die
als erster, als erste Verdachtdiagnose, kommt eine Exarbation der bekannten
COPD-Intrage oder eine COPD Exarbation oder eine exarztverbierte COPD-Intrage.
Kann man alles sagen?
Ja.
Zweiten Pynomonie, dritten.
Exaktation oder eine exakt verbierte COPD-Infrage kann man alles sagen.
Ja, und zweitens Neumonie.
Ja, und die Hyphenum wegen Gewichtperlust.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das sind die, das genau, das, was ich hören wollte.
Das sind die Differenzialdiagnosen, die Sie haben können.
Warum kommen Sie auf Bruncheil-Karzinum?
Warum?
Ja, Sie haben, nicht Sie haben, Sie haben, ja.
Sie haben seit zwei Monaten, in zwei Monaten
Sehn Kilo abgenommen.
Sehr gut, Gewichtsverlust und was noch?
Äh, bunutige Ausruf.
Sehr gut, genau.
Genau, und daran muss man denken, ne?
Das ist nicht allzu wenig bei diesen.
Und noch etwas kommt hinzu, was noch?
Gewichtsverlust, Hämoptysen und was noch?
Sie ist Raucherin, noch ein Risikofaktor für eine Bruncheil-Karzinum.
Langjährige Raucherin, ne?
Zwei Packungen seit 50 Jahren oder so, länger sogar.
Ja, das sind ja auch 100 Packiers, also da...
Über 100 Packiers.
Ja, also das heißt, das ist sehr, sehr gut, genau.
Das ist super, die Differenzialdiagnosen sind.
Weil ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie ja auch ein EKG geschrieben
während der Untersuchung, weil sie Patientin Luftnot angegeben hat.
Warum haben Sie das EKG geschrieben?
Wovor hatten Sie Angst?
Ja, ich habe uns vor Myocardiumfaktus.
Sehr gut, von einem Myocardiumfaktus
gibt es im Deutschen nicht.
Bitte nicht.
Ich habe von einem Myocardiumfaktus.
Ich hatte Angst, dass die Patientin ein Myocardiumfakt haben kann.
Sehr gut, also samt mit dem EKG, das fand ich auch sehr gut.
Kann sein.
Patienten haben manchmal stumme Infarkte.
Sie ist zwar keine Diabetes-Kerin,
aber sie hat Luftnot angegeben, ja?
Kann sein.
Und 2. Die Lungenembolie.
Ich finde nicht eine Super.
Warum?
Wie kommen Sie auf die Lungenembolie?
Warum kann es eine Lungenembolie sein?
Sie haben Luftnot beim Liegen, bei der Liege.
Luftnot?
Alleine Luftnot reicht schon aus.
Hemoptüse auch.
Hemoptüse auch und was noch?
Was haben Sie im EKG gesehen?
Ich habe extra gesagt, was ich im EKG gesehen habe.
Ich habe im EKG rechtchenkelblock gesagt.
Ich habe extra rechtchenkelblock gesagt,
damit sie durcheinander kommen.
Aber die Patienten, die natürlich eine COPD haben,
haben oftmals rechtchenkelblock,
weil das rechte Herz belastet einfach.
Okay?
Sehr gut.
Super.
Okay.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Wie kriegen Sie das alles jetzt unter einem Hut
und können mit wenig Diagnostik herausfinden
oder Diagnosen ausschließen?
Was machen Sie als erstes?
Labor haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, zuerst.
Woran gucken Sie im Labor?
Serpi und Sputumprobe.
Ein...
Woran gucken Sie im Labor?
Sputum ist im Labor.
Ja, wo ist der Blut?
Wo ist der Blut?
Ja, Serpi, Leukositen.
Und bei der Blutgasanalyse kontrolliere ich...
Ich frag nicht die Blutgasanalyse.
Ich frag jetzt nur Blut.
Okay, Serpi, Infektion,
oder Serpi, Prokastonin.
Sehr gut.
Super.
Warum?
Ja, wegen...
Ja, Prokastonin.
Eine Sekunde, eine Sekunde.
Tuba, Tuba.
Anne, Anne, ich habe dir den Baben geblieben.
Ich habe den Prokastonin,
Serpi ist die Entsündungsparameter,
die Sie kontrollieren.
Prokastonin ist früher gesteigt.
Langzeitige Infektionparameter.
Nein, wir reden nicht vom HP1C.
Was ist Prokastonin?
Worauf weiß Prokastonin,
dass es ganz wichtig ist,
auf bakterielle Infekte.
Ja.
Und nur deswegen,
nur Scholtern,
denn nur deswegen wird Prokastonin gemacht.
Okay?
Alles klar.
Gut, Leukositen, Serpi,
da haben wir schon mal Infekt,
Prämonien, welche Richtung das geht,
Infiltraten.
Was machen wir noch?
Wir haben gesagt,
wir können auch eine Herzinfizientin,
also was gucken wir uns mal vor?
Ja, ich kontrolliere auch
Detimer und...
Detimer ist sehr gut,
zum Beispiel um den Nebuli,
das heißt, wenn die Detimerin jetzt negativ wäre
oder aber die Patienten sind 70 Jahre alt,
man kann das ja alles, was entsprechen, berechnen.
Wenn die Detimerin bei 0,7 ist,
ist es auch negativ.
Eine Sekunde.
Okay.
Und Herzinfizientin,
ins Zufizient,
kontrolliere ich BNAP?
BNAP gibt es nicht.
BNP.
Bitte richtig sagen.
Der PSP-Prüfung ist auch
Fachsprachentrüfung.
Fachsprachentrüfung bedeutet,
wir sagen nicht myokart entfaktus,
sagen wir nicht, wir sagen myokart entfaktus.
Wir sagen Husten und wir sagen
BNP.
Pro BNP, ne?
Wir gucken nach Pro BNP.
Okay, sehr gut, genau.
Und wenn Pro BNP wird etwas erhöht sein,
aber nicht stark,
wenn die Patienten lange geziopidiert,
das rechte Herz,
ist belastet, das wird erhöht sein.
Also wegen der Rechtsherzbelastung.
Also,
Detimerin, mal gemacht,
in Sekunde halben,
haben wir schon viele Sachen ausgeschlossen.
Wenn die Detimerin negativ ist,
ist es schon mal keine Logenempolie.
Das kann man schon mal im Kopf abarbeiten.
Wenn BNP nicht so stark erhöht ist,
dann wissen wir, es ist auch keine Herzinfizientin,
keine Linkferdinfizientin.
Aber wir haben ja noch gesagt, was könnte es noch sein?
Was Böse hat es?
Das ist halt schwierig herausbekommen im Labor,
aber wir können ja mal die LDH machen
und gucken, wie die LDH ist.
Und dann, was sind wir ja auch ungefähr,
ob da irgendwie Hemmhulhüsezeichen sind
oder so oder Zellzerfalt.
Okay, und was machen wir als Nächstes?
Blutgasseanalyse ist eine super Idee.
Warum machen wir die Blutgasseanalyse?
Ja, nicht nur Aluminium,
aber auch Säopäde,
für Säopäde,
aber auch für Säopäde.
Nein, warum machen wir die Luminium?
Warum machen wir die Blutgasseanalese?
Was wollen Sie in der Blutgasseanalyse kontrollieren?
Kohlandioxid und Partial Kohlandioxid
kontrollieren wir.
Wir wollen P CO2 kontrollieren, richtig?
Ja, und
nach dieser Ergäbung.
Und P O2
wollen wir kontrollieren
und was wollen wir noch kontrollieren?
Ja, und
nach dieser Ergäbung.
Und die Kohle.
Die Carbonat.
Und noch pH Wert.
Carbonat und Laktat kontrollieren wir.
Und pH Wert vor allen Dingen.
Was ist bei COPD-Land das Wichtigere?
Laustock P O2
oder P CO2.
Was ist das Wichtigere?
P CO2.
Ja,
bei der COPD
erweitert
Lungenkapacität
und
Was bedeutet das?
Laustock.
Ja, die haben ein Lungenempfel sehen.
Die haben das Problem
das CO2 abzuatmen.
Ja, abzatmen.
Und was passiert jetzt?
Warum ist das wichtig,
die Blutgasseanalese?
Warum ist das wichtig?
Was müssen Sie machen?
Können wir
Laustock
umstellen?
Anpassen.
Genau.
Das heißt, der CO2 Wert,
der hoch ist.
50 ist schon hoch.
Aber COPD-Land haben immer einen hohen CO2.
Dann müssen Sie dürfen sowieso
einem COPD-Land nie mehr als
2 Liter Laustock geben.
Hallo?
Nie mehr
als 2 Liter Laustock geben.
Sollten Sie nie machen, warum?
Wenn wir
Höhe
Laustock geben
blockieren wir
Atmzentrum.
Atmen nicht mehr.
Sehr gut.
Super.
Der Atman-Antrieb ist weg.
Atmen ist weg.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Wenn der CO2 Wert nicht so hoch ist,
dann machen Sie das nicht.
Das ist ja eine gute Frage.
Wir haben ja schon mal gesprochen.
Hatten so wie ich.
Und hatten P2, 250.
Machen Sie sich Sorgen?
Nein, die muss nicht beatmeten.
Weil die redet noch ganz normal mit Ihnen.
Sie müssen nur Sauerstoff etwas niedriger geben.
Okay.
Was machen Sie noch?
Was ist das wichtigste,
die ganz einfache Unterrichtung.
Blutkartsanalyse, Labor.
Was haben Sie denn so lange gesagt?
Ich gehör die Lunge ab.
Ob Sie exorciert werden dürfen,
oder nicht.
Eine Einfache haben Sie nicht gemacht.
Die haben Sie nicht abgehorscht.
Ich hör die Lunge ab.
Ich orchestiere.
Ich höre die Lunge.
Ich höre die Lunge ab.
Ich höre...
Schreiben Sie sich das aus. Ich höre die Lunge ab.
Ja, ich höre die Lunge ab.
Und das ist nämlich das allerwichtigste bei COPD-Land. Was hören wir denn?
Ja.
Da Sonores Atmgeräusche haben.
Nein. Was ist ein sonores Atmgeräusch? Ist physiologisch.
Physiologisch, genau.
Was hören Sie bei Patienten mit einer COPD-Experts-Aktur?
Nein.
Feuchterasselgeräusche.
Nein. Feuchterasselgeräusche.
Nicht raten. Sie raten jetzt gerade.
Lassogeräusche.
Im Filtrate. Feuchterasselgeräusche.
Das will ich nicht hören. Was hören Sie bei einer COPD in der Lunge?
Spastik.
Spasmus. Sie hören Spasmus.
Und wie hört sich Spasmus an?
Giemen.
Spiratorisches.
Verlängerter Experium.
Und Brummen.
Entschuldigung.
Hört sich lustig an.
Aber so hört sich das an. Also nochmal.
Was hören Sie als allererstes bei der COPD?
Ich höre die Lunge.
Giemen.
Und Brummen.
Ich höre die Lunge ab erstmal.
Ich höre die Lunge ab.
Und was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte Giemen und Brummen und Verlängerter Experium.
Was ist denn Giemen?
Giemen ist der Ausdruck eines verlängerten Experiums.
Weil Sie nicht ausatmen können.
Weil es eng ist, kommt es Giemen.
Und Giemen bedeutet Verlängerter Experium.
Sehr gut. Und das ist Spastik.
Und wie therapieren Sie das?
Sie können ihr sofort helfen.
Ja.
Zuerst werden wir Branko dilatato.
Nein, nicht als allererstes.
Verlangen, dass ich IV kurze soll.
Erst mal.
IV gibt es nicht.
Wir sind in der Facharztsprachentrüffung.
Ich sage Sie es richtig. Was geben wir?
Ich gebe Kurtisol intravenös.
Sehr gut.
Oder IV? Bitte sagen Sie IV.
IV.
BNP.
Sagen Sie das.
IV.
Und wir haben noch etwas falsch gesagt.
Also Sie geben Kurtisol intravenös sehr gut.
Wie viel?
Okay.
Jede Kilo ein Milligramm.
Ja.
Aber geben Sie ruhig 100 Milligramm.
100 Milligramm Solidekortin IV.
Sehr gut.
Und wenn Sie wollen, können Sie sogar jetzt noch inhalieren lassen.
Inhalation.
Mit Bronschodilatatoren inhalieren lassen.
Super.
Und Sie haben er jetzt schon wirklich wirklich geholfen.
Wirklich.
Und ja.
Okay.
Weiter.
Das heißt, wir haben abgehorscht.
Wir haben die Lunge abgehört.
Wir haben Laborwerte gemacht.
Wir haben eine andere Symptom.
Die Chemoglobin ist in Ordnung,
weil sie hat ja Hemoptysis,
wir müssen gucken, ne?
Und wir haben ein Röntgenbild gemacht.
Aber ein Röntgenbild sieht man nur ein M4W-Aspekt von der Lunge.
Keine Sicherung in Filtrate.
Wenn die Patienten jetzt Gewichtsverlust und alles möglich
jetzt angegeben hat,
würden Sie nicht doch weitergehen
und liefern noch eine andere Untersuchung machen bei Ihnen?
Danke.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das meine ich nicht.
Sie haben das Korax.
Aber etwas besseres als ein Röntgen Torax.
Sie hat doch Gewichtsverlust.
Wie dem Röntgen Torax.
Was würden Sie noch machen?
Torax Computer Tormongerie.
Sehr gut.
Ein CT Torax würden wir machen.
Genau.
Warum?
Erstens, wir sehen,
ob Sie eine Lumenimbolle hat.
Und zweitens, wir machen das aber weswegen?
Ja, wir machen das mit der Lumenkarschnone.
Die Patienten haben die Lumenkarschnone auszuschließen.
Sehr gut.
Die Lisa hat die Lumenkarschnone auszuschließen.
Super, sehr gut.
Wirklich.
Jetzt aber mal ganz ehrlich.
Die Patienten hat tatsächlich eine Lumenkarschnone.
Haben Sie gesehen im CT?
Wie erklären Sie das jetzt?
Die Patienten, eigentlich.
Ich frage Sie,
ob Sie das voll macht?
macht, sagt, warum fragen Sie erst, ob Sie voll machten? Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn Sie
nicht gut denken oder nachdenken? Nein, ist Sie nicht. Sie ist nicht demant. Sie ist nicht
demant. Sie ist voll orientiert. Also Sie müssen mit der Patientin bitte reden und
wegen dieser Krankheiten werden wir Sie bei Onkologie überweisen.
Onkologisch vorstellen, bei unseren Onkologen vorstellen, immer sagen.
Man kann Will machen vorstellen. Die Patientin versteht, dass man sagt, wie werden Sie noch bei unseren Onkologen vorstellen?
Was weiß ich? Was weiß ich? Ich habe eine COPD. Das weiß ich.
Ja, in ihrer Atemweg, Atemweg gibt es eine Herausforderung.
Herausforderung? Es gibt eine Round-Forderung. Ja, ich habe eine COPD. Das weiß ich, dass ich eine COPD habe.
Ja, COPD ist ganz andere Krankheiten. Es gibt hier eine Round-Forderung, eine Bösartige,
Bösartige GWB. Das heißt, meine COPD ist bösartig geworden? Es ist auch bösartig, aber es wird behandelt.
Es ist behandbar. Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden, was Sie mir sagen wollen. Was habe ich jetzt an der Lunge?
Wir haben in Ihrer Atemweg eine Tumor. Die Patientin versteht nur, woran ist Tumor?
Wir haben eine Lungentumor. Alles klar.
Jetzt sagen Sie mir nochmal, wie man die COPD einteilt.
Die COPD ist 4 Grad.
Achso, eine Untersuchung kann man doch vergessen. Wir machen noch eine Lungenfunktionsprüfung. Das haben wir vergessen.
Ja.
Daran Sie der Patientin bitte erklären, wie etwas eine Lungenfunktionsprüfung ist.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, werdet mir für Sie einen Lungenfunktion-Test veranlassen.
Zuerst können Sie mit Ruhe ein- und zuatmen.
Und dann möchte ich von Ihnen sehr stark einatmen.
Und dann mit dieser Pipette, mit dieser Röhre, in dieser Röhre, mit gut verschlossenem Mundlippen,
gut verschlossenem Lippen, feste, so schnell Sie können, feste, alles raus.
Okay, aber ich wollte etwas anderes jetzt.
Jetzt teilen Sie mir mal die COPD-Stadien ein.
Die Patientin braucht nicht...
Nein, ich möchte einfach nur wissen, ganz nach Text, nach Lehrbuch, wie teilt man COPD ein?
Nach welchen Stadien, wie heißen die Stadien?
Die Patientin für das Patientin.
Wie wird die COPD eingeteilt? Nach welchen Stadien wird COPD eingeteilt?
Goldstadien, Gold, G-O-L-D, Gold.
Den Begriff müssen Sie aber wirklich wissen.
Goldstadien, einmal sagen wir mal, Goldstadien.
Und wie viele Stadien gibt es nach Gold?
Sehr gut, genau.
Und wonach sind die Kriterien, wonach wird es eingeteilt?
Nach welchem Parameter?
Ein Sekund in Kapazität.
Forstierte Expiration.
Fürstierte 1 Sekund in Kapazität.
Danach wird es eingeteilt.
Dann gibt es aber, glaube ich, auch noch dieses ABC.
Das ist irgendwie nach Extraterbation, glaube ich, wird das noch eingeteilt.
Das weiß ich aber auch nicht.
Das heißt, bei dieser Patientin müssten wir die Lohen Funktionsprüfungen sehen.
Und wenn die 1 Sekund in Kapazität unter 40 ist, zum Beispiel, dann hat sich schon mal Stadion 3,4.
Und dann, wenn man halt öfters Exerzivation hat, ich kann das auch nicht so gut.
Mich tut es jetzt auch nach Leserbach, dass Sie das einmal gehört haben.
Okay?
Okay.
Und Antibiotiktherapie, weil COPD-Patienten sind wir großzügig.
Auch wenn das Therapie nicht so hoch erhöht ist, wir geben großzügig.
Wenn Sie die klinischen Anzeichen haben.
Und Sie haben eben noch etwas Richtiges gesagt.
Entschuldigung, dass ich noch nicht drauf eingegangen bin.
Ja, Sie braucht auch, Sie muss auch Sputum mit mir einschicken.
Eine Mikrobiologie.
Dann sagen Sie Mikrobiologie.
Sputum geht in die Mikrobiologie.
Super.
Also insgesamt, wenn, haben Sie noch Fragen?
Leofloxacin werden wir verschreiben.
Bei der COPD?
Ja.
Also wir können ja mal ganz einfach anfangen bei der COPD erstmal mit dem Antibiotikum.
Also das einfachste.
Wir können mit z. B. Ziprofloxacin anfangen.
Ja.
Und dann geben wir noch etwas für die Atypschenkeine dazu.
Zum Beispiel Klaritromycin, Acetromycin.
Ja.
Und dann warten wir Antilogramm ab.
Und dann können wir das immer noch umstellen.
Und dann wird nach drei Tagen, kann man es ja immer noch umstellen.
Ja.
Also man muss immer bei COPD Patienten auch etwas für die Atypschenkeine noch geben.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, das war...
Ich bin sehr übtlich.
Ich habe sehr viel gemacht.
Aber Prüfung wird auch so sein.